today we're going to talk about how to
neutralize the bad effects from
consuming sugar
breads pasta alcohol
and other things not that you would ever
go up in your program and sheet but
let's say your friends and family and
you want to share this information with
them I'm going to show you how to
counter some of the bad side effects
that can occur when you eat junk foods
and other things now what's interesting
about this topic is if you go to the
experts and I'm talking about even
organizations like the American arm
Association they will still allow you to
consume sugar and alcohol and as long as
it's part of a balanced diet it's
totally fine they don't see too much
problem with it like even for sugar they
allow us nine teaspoons of sugar for men
and six teaspoons for women now this is
not even counting the carbohydrates in
fact for carbohydrates they recommend up
to 65 percent of all your calories can
be carbohydrates that just blows me away
you have these experts in the field and
I guess what makes a person expert is
how much education they have how many
degrees they have
I mean what's so ironic about that is
this is just my personal belief and this
is the generality
um I think the more education a person
has the more they're educated in a
certain thought pattern and they have a
lessened ability to think freely I mean
I'll even give an example with myself I
went through pre-med and then I went
through Chiropractic College which is
definitely different than medical school
but I quickly found out there's just not
enough time to learn the quantity of
data that they cram down your throat so
what we did as a substitute is memorize
okay we memorize information regurgitate
it on a test get through the test and
then get on to the next subject and so
there's a really big difference between
learning the information understanding
it being able to apply it and memorizing
it when you memorize something it does
not mean that you learn it and it can
apply it and even that you understand it
so this is what I've been doing the last
30 years after I graduated
taking time to really understand the
concepts observe it question it make
sure it's true because who knows if all
this information that they're teaching
in the universities is actually true or
not and this is my own personal
experience
I felt that after I graduated I felt I
was dumber than when I went in because I
was filled with so many confusions I
didn't have a chance to apply this
information but they do have internships
things that help you apply so I got a
little distracted I digressed let's get
back to the topic at hand all right
number one sugar what happens when you
eat sugar is you have several things
going on you have a spike in your blood
sugars especially if you eat something
that is high on the glycemic index which
basically means it spikes your sugar
fast and the faster it spikes the sugar
the worse off your health will be and so
we have this negative effect from the
glycemic index of foods but we also have
another index I'm not sure if you ever
heard about this but it's called the
glycemic load which looks at the
quantity of carbohydrates in that food
so that's a little bit different because
they take the glycemic index and then
they multiply it times the amount of
carbohydrates divided by 100 get this
number and then that is put on another
scale so for example you might eat
something low on the glycemic index okay
but it's not as low on the glycemic lobe
but like watermelon for example it's low
in the glycemic index but it's higher on
the glycemic low because there's a lot
of carbohydrates in it okay then you
have pineapple which is considered low
but on the glycemic load it's higher and
then you have a banana which is
considered low but the glycemic load is
higher so my only point on that is that
when you have more fiber you can buffer
this sugar response so the first thing
you need to know is that if you eat
sugar make sure you also add fiber with
it or close to that meal to help buffer
the response of the sugar the more fiber
you eat with the sugar the less the
insulin response and one of the problems
with eating sugar is it triggers insulin
and fiber is one of the two things that
won't trigger insulin the second thing
when you consume refined sugar okay you
are going to deplete certain nutrients
specifically
or mostly potassium and vitamin B1 but
you also deplete calcium magnesium and
zinc and even some other things but
potassium and B1 are the two big ones
that will get depleted because as your
body either burns the sugar or stores
the sugar it takes potassium and B1 to
be able to perform this so if you end up
eating refined sugar you need to take
potassium maybe you have a big salad as
well as maybe taking some nutritional
yeast or just vitamin B1 because that
will at least counter the deficiencies
that you just created because when the
potassium goes lower your pulse rate
will go higher when your B1 goes lower
your anxiety and nervous tension goes
higher all right the next point about
sugar and this is kind of interesting if
you're a diabetic or a pre-diabetic or
have a lot of sugar going through your
bloodstream because you just ate sugar
there's going to be a lot of damage to
forward parts of your body the eye
the kidney
the nervous system which includes your
brain
and the inside of your arteries and so
you can think about the sugar as
something that's rusting out or
corroding the body tissue so because
you're getting a lot of free radical
damage in something called oxidation
so there are some things that you can do
to counter that to greatly reduce the
complications of not just diabetes but
the complications of all the sugar
that's flowing through your bloodstream
so if you happen to know someone who ate
a lot of sugar or know someone who has
diabetes including yourself this is what
I would also include benphotamine okay
which is a type of B1 that is fat
soluble that protects the nerves it
protects the eyes it protects the kidney
it protects the heart and then alpha
lipoic acid both of those act as a
powerful antioxidant to counter the
complications of diabetes or if there's
a lot of sugar going through your body
now the next point I want to bring up
about sugar is just if you have extra
sugar let's say you have something
called the dawn phenomena where you wake
up in the morning and you have all this
like you didn't even eat sugar just went
higher in your body or let's say you ate
sugar and the sugar is high you can burn
it off by exercising you can go for a
long walk like 20 minutes or 30 minutes
and burn off that extra sugar so that's
another way to counter the sugar that's
flowing through your body in addition to
that apple cider vinegar greatly helps
regulate your blood sugars you mix it
with water like a tablespoon and it will
greatly improve your blood sugars as
well as lower your insulin
cinnamon is another very potent herb or
spice to lower your blood sugars and as
a supplement berberine is another one
that is almost comparable to metformin
to help regulate blood sugars and
without the side effects the next point
I want to bring up about sugar is
something called the insulin index we
talked about how sugar can cradle these
problems but what about insulin itself
because when you eat refined
carbohydrates or sugar you jack up
insulin and the lower things are on the
insulin index the better they are the
higher they are
the worse off you are okay so at the
very lowest point on the insulin index
you have pure fats as you start going up
the scale normally fat doesn't come as
fat it comes with other things like
protein for example so the more fat it
comes with the protein the lower the
insulin Spike so for example if you ate
egg whites compared to the yolk that
would be a much higher insulin Spike
than if you ate the whole egg with the
yolk if you ate nuts for example that
are lower in fat versus a pecan or a
macadamia nut is going to be a big
difference in where that is on the
insulin index
and then if we take a protein that has
like no fat in it that's very very high
on the insulin index so whey protein
powder is really bad for your blood
sugars so the reason I'm bringing that
up is that if you add more fat to your
meal you'll buffer the insulin response
now we can combine all this together
let's say you have a salad with all the
phytonutrients that can actually counter
some of the uh the free radical damage
from the sugar right and then we add the
oil olive oil to help buffer any type of
insulin response there and then we also
add vinegar because I mentioned apple
cider vinegar lowering your blood sugars
we can add balsamic vinaigrette now you
have this amazing countering effect
basically you're just having salad with
dressing to help buffer the bad effects
from sugar all right the next thing you
could do to counter the bad effects from
sugar and other things would be just to
do fasting okay what does fasting do it
turns on all the repair genes in your
body so your body is going to go in this
repair mode and very potently repair
damage from things that you just did
whether
from alcohol refined carbs or just pure
sugar
so
fasting is a very important thing also
fasting will stimulate your own body's
antioxidants and that will counter the
free radical damage from the sugar the
next point I want to bring up is about
your brain if given the choice between
glucose or sugar
and ketones your brain will choose
ketones over sugar
so how can you apply that let's say for
example you eat something really sugary
well your brain is going to suck that
right in right it's going to affect your
cognitive skills your your mood and all
sorts of things right if you took MCT
oil which turns into ketones really fast
so that will act as a substitute so your
brain will grab the ketones instead of
the sugar and at least mentally you're
going to feel a lot better than if you
didn't do that let's say for example you
went off the program and you had some
alcohol how can you counter that well
you have a hangover right I'm going to
show you how to counter that but then
you also have the damage that it's done
to the liver so there's an enzyme your
liver produces
to turn that alcohol into another
chemical it's called acetaldehyde which
is like 30 times more toxic than actual
alcohol and so the bad feeling that you
get when you drink alcohol like a
hangover is from that byproduct it's
kind of like an intermediate chemical in
the process of trying to break down
alcohol and so you can take vitamin B1
to help counter that Toxin and that will
reduce your hangover the other problem
with alcohol it's very dehydrating so if
you were to take some electrolytes okay
and more water you would feel better as
well because your brain is now
dehydrated some people do pickle juice
you can also do electrolyte powder you
can add sea salt with more water to
counter that the other really cool thing
you can do is take the herb milk thistle
which has very special properties for
your liver okay it protects the liver it
reduces the effect of alcohol destroying
the cells and this other condition
called autophagy which is the recycling
of damaged tissue in your body it will
actually increase that all right number
three drugs okay so this goes beyond
sugar or refined carbs and alcohol let's
say you take medication there are some
side effects that are going to occur if
you took milk thistle that would protect
your liver but here's the catch a lot of
medications use the same enzymes as milk
thistle so you don't want to take it at
the same time okay because that might
decrease the effect of the drug I would
just recommend take the milk thistle at
a different time of the day so that way
of the protection but you don't
interfere with the drug a couple little
points about drugs metformin depletes
B12 and B1 so you want to take those two
drugs to prevent a condition called
lactic acid doses which is very
dangerous statins deplete consume Q10 so
you want to take more colenzyme to Q10
if you take statins antibiotics kill off
your good bacteria and then you end up
with a yeast infection
anytime you take an antibiotic you
should always take a probiotic at the
same time and acids destroy the acid in
the stomach putting you in a situation
you now are going to have a hard time
absorbing minerals killing off viruses
and other bacteria also take apple cider
vinegar and water and betaine
hydrochloride most of those remedies
will probably fix your acid reflux
anyway all right the next point about
grains whether that's bread pasta cereal
crackers biscuits things like that
grains are filled with phytic acid which
blocks trace minerals and other minerals
like zinc iron iodine calcium magnesium
manganese and many other minerals so if
you're doing a lot of grain products you
want to make sure that you replace these
trace minerals and minerals and it just
so happens that the two top best foods
for doing that would be organ Meats like
liver and that gives you really good
bioavailable zinc and iron and other
minerals like selenium but also
shellfish will do it when you consume
fish that's high in mercury that could
be very problematic to various things
like your thyroid so you want to take
the antidote to Mercury and that is
selenium selenium binds up with Mercury
making Mercury no longer toxic to the
body and so the fish that are high in
mercury are like shark swordfish and
tuna Seafood that are low in mercury are
like salmon Cod oyster sardines shrimp
and canned tuna that's light and there
are many more all right number six let's
say you ate too much sodium or just
table salt right or you had MSG
monosodium glutamate which is a lot of
sodium and you feel all swollen and
puffy you can take potassium to counter
that so the more sodium chloride you
have or the more sodium you have the
more potassium you need to counter that
so that would definitely be like leafy
greens or a big salad couple last points
on this topic if you found that you ate
too much food and you feel bloated you
could take betaine hydrochloride and or
outside of vinegar to speed up the
digestion to how help you reduce the
bloating next Point oxalates let's say
you ate a lot of spinach or almonds that
are high in oxalates which tend to
irritate your joints or increase your
risk for kidney stones you can take
Dairy that has calcium to counter the
oxalates this is why people that take
spinach also might have some feta cheese
with it and also if you add lemon to it
you get the citrates to also bind with
the oxalate stones to prevent kidney
stones so calcium and citrate will
counter oxalates and last point when you
go into ketogenic diet
you're going to get rid of fluid and you
might also find that you're low on
electrolytes and B vitamins I would
recommend using nutritional yeast now if
you haven't seen this video on what
would happen if you gave up sugar for 14
days it's really interesting I put it up
right here check it out